[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIN SODERBERG: Thank you very
much for joining us today.
We'll be talking with Tom
Miller about his new novel,
"The Philosopher's Flight."
I actually went to
high school with Tom.
We're both proud graduates
of Wauwatosa West High
School in Wauwatosa, Wisconsin.
And from there, Tom
went on to study
at Harvard, Notre Dame, and
the University of Pittsburgh.
And he's an ER
doctor in Madison.
And I'll actually let Tom
tell you a little bit more
about himself and
about his new book.
TOM MILLER: Yes.
So, I'm a second year
resident right now,
and took time off for
medicine to write full time,
and wrote the book we're
going to talk about and read
a little bit from today.
During that time,
and sort of really
worked on revising
it during that time.
It had been a
project I started--
I think, in earnest-- around
the end of 2009 or early 2010,
but had been kicking
around some of the ideas
for going back probably
almost 10 or 15 years now.
What do you need to know?
Let's see, should I
describe the book,
or describe the
world a little bit?
ERIN SODERBERG: Yeah,
Give us a synopsis.
TOM MILLER: It's the trouble
with fantasy novels, much
less historical fantasy novels.
But you really only need
to know three things
about "The
Philosopher's Flight."
Thing number one is that this
is set in America in 1917
in a world in which magic--
though nobody calls it magic--
it's empirical philosophy,
and it's definitely not magic.
But magic was discovered
about 200 years earlier
and caused the world to evolve
in a different way as a result.
Thing number two
you should know is
women are a lot better at
philosophy, or sigilry--
as it's also known--
than men.
And that has caused a lot
of suspicion and hostility
over the years.
And thing number three is that
the protagonist, whose name
is Robert Weekes, is one
of the rare men who is
good at empirical philosophy--
which makes him a
little bit unusual.
ERIN SODERBERG: Great.
Would you mind reading to us?
TOM MILLER: Yeah.
So, I'm going to
read a little bit
from the middle, which
is sort of doubly
a dangerous thing to do.
So to catch you up
on what's happened,
Robert has grown
up his whole life
raised by his mother
and his three sisters.
All of them are
really very gifted,
very powerful philosophers,
and sort of brought him up
to do it as well.
He ends up earning a scholarship
to Radcliffe College, which,
if you want to study
philosophy, obviously,
you go to a women's
school to do that.
So Robert is one of three
men at Radcliffe in 1917.
And that meets with all sorts
of skepticism or cattiness
or outright hostility
and violence at times.
He has dreamed his
whole life of following
in his mother's footsteps.
His mother was part of the
United States Sigilry Corps,
which is sort of
the military version
of empirical philosophy.
And she was what's termed
a rescue and evacuation
helicopter, so our rescue
and evacuation flyer.
So, if, like me, you grew up
watching episodes of "M*A*S*H"
where the helicopters
fly in with the wounded
at the beginning, that
is sort of what they do,
though I should show you
the pictures of this.
So, flyers-- and
this requires me
to back up and probably
explain a little bit more
about how philosophy works.
But Robert, when he flies,
where's the harness?
And part of the reason he wears
a harness is to keep his powder
bag attached to his body so
he doesn't lose it or drop it.
The way philosophy
works is that you
draw figures called sigils with
particular kinds of powder.
So for different effects,
you draw different types
of pictures, different
sigils or symbols.
And those produce
different effects.
To fly, he has a mix of corn
powder-- so very finely ground
corn meal, as well as sand
and some other chemicals--
and a large 8 or 12 pound
bag with a regulator
at the end with
a fine tip on it,
so he can control how fast
the powder trickles through.
Every eight seconds or so,
he draws a different symbol.
And that continues to provide
power so that he can fly.
I think that's really about
all that you need to know.
So Robert's dreamed
his whole life
of following in his
mother's footsteps
and joining in rescue
and evacuation.
And of course, that's
impossible because he's a man.
And no man has ever
done that before.
So this is from
chapter 21, for those
of you following along at home.
"The following week
brought with it further
miracles and wonders.
Brock--" oh, dear.
So, Professor Brock is
one of the professors
of practical or
empirical philosophy.
And she teaches flying.
"Professor Brock
reopened the aerodrome
and unveiled our new
hovering instructors--
10 corps veterans who'd been
pensioned off due to age.
All the Radcliffe women who
were still interested in flying
assembled on the landing
field to be divided up
among the old crones.
One after the next,
the instructor
stepped forward to call out
the names of their trainees
and lead them into
the aerodrome.
But my name wasn't
on any of the lists.
I would have thought I was
being singled out again,
but Essy was left
unassigned, too.
We stood alone on the field
looking for some indication
of what we were supposed to do.
'Bookkeeping,
here?' I suggested.
Essy chewed at her lip.
An ancient lady leaning
heavily on a cane
hobbled out of the aerodrome.
She wore thick spectacles and
had a pair of field glasses
on a leather strap
around her neck.
She hadn't been introduced
with the other instructors.
She stopped in front of us
and straightened painfully.
'Well, this is a sorry state
of affairs,' she drawled.
'Out of this entire
aerodrome, only two hoverers
have dared mule the phrase
rescue and evacuation
in connection with
their own names.
One is fewer flight hours than
any of my great grandchildren,
and the other has a phallus.'
As he blushed to hear
such coarse language,
the old lady pointed at her.
'You're Sarah Stewart?' 'Oh,
ma'am, I go by Essy, if--
'That's a weak name,
a child's name.
Stop using it.
Now, get kitted out and scout
me three different landing
approaches to Harvard Square.'
'Ma'am, we're not allowed to
hover between--' 'The Cambridge
Police Department has
no way to catch you.
I want you to land and
then record the paper
three approaches
with compass headings
and lists of potential
obstructions for each.
Give it to me in one hour.
Get a bag and get up.'
If Essy was torn
about committing
a technically illegal act, she
overcame her doubts quickly.
She tried it toward
the aerodrome.
'Run!' The woman bellowed, as
he accelerated to a sprint.
'And you,' the old lady said.
'Let me see if I
have this right.
Conducted a solo
search and rescue
mission over rough
country in Montana
and lifted out three souls.
Dove into the river here
to save a drowning hoverer.
Ran a mass casualty
evacuation on zero minutes
notice, and flew a
goddamn 40 foot stringer.
I would say that just about
makes you the best male flyer
in the world, doesn't it?'
'No, ma'am,' I said.
'Oh, Mother Mary,
but he doesn't understand.
Child, I was in
the corps 55 years.
That's before
modern hovering was
invented, to save you the math.
Back at '11, they
said to me, Gertrude,
you're too old to fly.
So I instructed
at Fort McConnell.
Then, this year,
they said, Gertrude,
you're are to mean to teach.
We've got a war on, and we don't
want every third girl quitting.
So they retired me.
And Janet Brock, with all her
gold medals and monographs
and Professor of
Such and Such, said
she had a man worth training--
a man for the corps, for RNE.
What better revenge for
invaliding me out than
to dump on them a man
who's too good to refuse.
So, do you think a moment of
my prodigious experience would
waste her golden years on
anything less than the finest
male flyer on Earth?'
'No, ma'am," I said.
'Good.
I want you to believe it.
I want you to train like it.
And if you choose not
to boast about it,
then that's your business,' as
if I would dare have said such
a thing in the aerodrome.
'Show me your hands'
Gertrude said.
I extended my hands for her.
I had dirt under my
nails and calluses
all rough and yellowed,
but she wasn't
checking for cleanliness.
She produced a tape measure
from the work bag at her hip
and measured my thumb
and index finger, then
across my palm in several
different dimensions.
'You have lovely, long,
girlish fingers,' she said,
nodding her approval.
'Do you know how to fly a lever
regulator?' 'I grew up with
them,' I answered.
'Then, no more
the dial regulator
trash they favor here.
You'll fly a Chesapeake Mark 20
lever regulator with a 2 inch
conical tip, three twist
bird board to 80 mil.'
'I don't think we have--'
'Janet found a used one.
She ground the tips herself.
Now, kneel, or I won't
be able to reach.'
I knelt and she made
further measurements
across my neck, chest, hips,
thighs, belly, and shoulders,
recording each with the stub
of a pencil in a little book.
'Beg your pardon,' she muttered.
She put few glances
to her eyes in time
to Essy dash out of the
aerodrome in full harness.
'Run, run, run,'
the woman bellowed.
Essy flung herself into the air.
The old lady checked
her wrist chronometer.
'6 minutes and 40
seconds to kit out,
and then a three step launch.
Christ in a fish barrel.
And she flies
pretty, god damn it.'
She turned back to me.
'Brown, or black?'
She asked.
'Excuse me?' 'You're riding a
Springfield harness with a lot
of homemade improvements?'
'Yes,' I said.
'Not anymore.
We're bringing you up
to the 20th century.
Janet should have had you in
custom tackle from the day you
came in.'
'Oh, I can't afford--'
'You're not paying for it.
Brown leather, or black?'
'Brown.' She noted that
too, and put her book away.
'Now, what do you weigh first
thing in the morning after
you've voided?'
She didn't mean
anything untoward by it,
and I didn't take it that way.
'I'm not sure,' I said. 'I don't
have a--' 'Then buy a scale
later today.
Give me an estimate.' '211.'
She winced.
'Your stand 72 and
1/2 inches tall.
I don't want to fly
above 186 pounds.
Are you going to faint
on me at that weight?'
'Probably not,' I said.
'Then you're on a diet
starting this morning,
unless you care to
dabble in transporting
to improve your figure.
I don't judge.
Powder flow for your current
weight will be 8.9 ounces per
minute.'
I was aghast at the
powdered expenditure,
not her comments regarding
weight loss, which
was simple physics.
'A little more cornmeal
than you used back home?'
She asked.
'Four times more,' I said.
'I'd be burning through
powdered like mad.'
'Well, you're not paying
for that, either.'
Then she laid herself
down on the ground.
'Prove you're worth the effort.
I'll play the role
of your casualty.
As fast as you can, I want
you to run into that building,
kit out, and grab
whatever style of harness
you intend to fly me in.
Then launch, take me 2 miles
out to sea, turn and land
back here.
And, oh, shoot.
You happened to be out of
silver chloride this morning.
Supply me awake.
Clear?' 'Perfectly.'
'Then, run,' she bellowed.
I grabbed my harness and
sprinted for the aerodrome.
'And if you can't do this in
half the time it took that
little daddy's girl, I'm sending
you straight back to the farm.'
I sprinted harder.
There was a line of women
snaking out the door waiting
to draw powder and equipment.
One of the other old sigil
women watched my approach.
'Clear the way for a hot e-vac!'
She yelled.
The girl stepped aside
to let me through.
Professor Brock was
behind the counter.
'A 2 and 1/2 general
purpose bag,' I pounded.
'Chesapeake 20 ounce regulator
with a 2 inch--' 'Fine, fine.'
Roxanne handed over
the items that she'd
had waiting right beside her.
I'd already slipped
into my harness
and was cinching
down the leg straps.
'I hope you're enjoying
yourself,' Professor Brock
said.
'I had to message every--'
'--and a 20 foot loop of 1 inch
cotton webbing.
Brock looked flummoxed.
'Oh, come on,' I said.
I attached my bag to my
hip as Brock pulled out
the aerodrome's catalog
to see where we stocked
such a piece of rigging.
The old lady at
the door laughed.
She took a cloth bag from her
belt and tossed it underhand
to me. 'Gertrude's 74 years
old,' the only slightly younger
woman said.
'Be gentle.' 'Yes, ma'am,' I
answered, and ran back out.
I shook the webbing
out of its bag.
It was nothing more
than a single long strap
with ends sewn together but
it made the world's quickest
harness.
I skidded to a stop
next to Gertrude,
who was lying flat on her
back, and laid the webbing out
in a circle around her."
At this point, I have
to stop and tell you
about a job I used to have.
I was an EMT basic
for a number of years.
And the only thing
I remember how
to do from my vehicle
rescue course,
in which we learned to use
the jaws of life and fun stuff
like that, is a
harness that you can
use for lowering
somebody out of a window,
or dragging somebody
across the ground.
I never actually had to
do it on a living human,
but it's actually very easy.
All you do is pull the
rope up between the legs,
and then reach under
the armpits, pull up,
and you have a harness sort of
like your playing Cat's Cradle.
"I skidded to a stop
next to Gertrude
who was lying flat on her
back, and laid out the webbing
in a circle around her.
'Oh, for the love of Saint
Jude, are you serious?
Web harness?' 'You said as
fast as I could,' I gasped.
'So do it.'
I yanked a loop of webbing
up beneath her feet
and up between her
legs, then reached
through it to pull up the
strap from under her armpits.
I hauled her to her feet
and clipped to my harness
so that we were
chest-to-chest, the old lover's
clinch position,
undignified, but fast.
'Go!' She barked.
I launched, trying
to make it gentle,
and then poured on speed as
I rushed toward the Atlantic.
I was unbalanced, my
regulator was unfamiliar,
and the power flow
rate was absurd.
I struggled to keep
us on the level.
We reached the ocean
in three minutes.
I turned and reversed course.
'You OK?' I asked.
'Had worse,' she replied.
'Mind me asking,
ever land like this?'
'Nope.'
Over the field, I
descended briskly.
'I have bad hips,' Gertrude
warned. 'Bad ankles,
bad knees--' I cut our vertical
speed and splayed my feet wide
so that she touched down first.
This had the
unintended consequence
of thrusting my pelvis
right into her bosom.
I brought my legs down crumbling
into a crouch to support her.
I had to grab her rump to
keep us from toppling over.
Some bright young thing
gave us a wolf whistle.
'Quiet on the field!'
Gertrude bellowed.
I unclipped her and
retrieved her cane.
She polished her glasses and
set them back on her nose.
'Wonderful at my age, that I
should experience something
new,' she proclaimed.
Are you married Mr. Weekes?
I blushed crimson. 'No, ma'am.
I'm terribly sorry that I
touched--' 'Sorry nothing.
I grabbed every last
piece of wounded soldiers
to get them up and down.
No, Mr. Weekes,
you misunderstand.
Better for you if
you were married.
Go pick one of those pretty
girls, make lots of babies--
girl babies, if you please--
and teach them to fly.
Your daughters
will be brilliant.
'Was I that bad?'
I asked.
'No, you dumb ass,
you're adequate.
A woman who flew like that
could get a test Fort Putnam
tomorrow.
And she'd be in
France by Christmas.
If you were shorter, I'd suggest
a wig and a set of bosom pads,
but you'd never pass for a lady.
So for you, a man,
to join RNE, you're
going to have to fly perfect.
And that's a
miserable existence.
I wouldn't wish it on you.
Go and settle down instead.'
I had a brief
vision of Dar in me
with a brood of
daughters, all of them
with dark, wavy hair
and perpetual frowns,
scolding me on some
point of politics
and then flying rings around me.
I rather liked it,
but not just yet.
'I came to fly,' I said.
Gertrude nodded, as if it would
have been impossible for me
to answer differently. 'Then fly
it again unladen at best speed,
and show me your hottest
landing.'" And I think
I'll stop it there.
ERIN SODERBERG: Thank you.
So, as we've just
heard, the novel
is set during World War I,
predominantly in Boston.
And one aspect of this book that
I find particularly striking
is how it manages to both feel
very historically accurate,
like this this could
have actually been
the world during World
War I, but it also
feels really relevant today.
There are a lot of
issues and themes
in the book that also feel
like this book could happen now
in the same way.
So, as far as the
historical context goes,
how much historical
research did you do?
TOM MILLER: I think the
best answer to that is some,
or that would be my degree from
the University of Wikipedia
on that sort of thing.
So, I've read some on both
on the First World War
and a couple of books on
the suffrage movement,
as well as sort of
letters home from women
who were in the Red Cross and
other things from that era--
so some research
into the era itself.
And then, the important
thing for me as well,
was sort of working out
that alternative timeline.
Because really, in
this world, women
have had the vote
for about 50 years.
So in some ways, that's
sort of more similar to
if you're doing it based
on actual history--
more like the 1960s,
in some ways--
women have had effective
widespread cheap
and readily available birth
control for about 50 years
as well at this
point, which maybe
makes it something
closer to 2015
in some of the social mores.
But in other ways, things
have not advanced that much.
So trying to figure out
socially, politically,
and economically where are
we in terms of evolution,
were important questions.
So some of it is set in a
world very close to 1917.
And other parts of it are
much more contemporary.
ERIN SODERBERG: Yeah.
So the parts of it that feel
really culturally relevant
today, those were
done on purpose.
TOM MILLER: Somewhat.
And I started writing
it a long time ago.
If we say it was seven
years or so in the writing,
it was back in about 2010
that I started a lot of it.
I didn't write it particularly
with the Me Too moment in mind
or with the idea of sort of
regressive sexual politics
in the executive branch.
But those things
ended up happening.
So it was sort of a
confluence of things.
So it's a little bit on
purpose, but not quite.
ERIN SODERBERG: One
of the many ways
in which this book feels
very current and timely
is this whole concept of
being other or being different
in the world that the
protagonist is in.
So, as you said
earlier, Robert is
one of only a few men at an
all girls school studying
a predominantly
female discipline.
This all feels very
close to home for me.
I'm a female software engineer.
So sometimes, I also
feel the same way
that Robert must feel
from time to time.
And philosophers,
in general, are
treated as outcasts and even
with violence by some people.
And in the opening sentence of
the book, Robert's daughter--
this is in the future from
where the part that Tom read--
his daughter asks him,
why do so many people hate
empirical philosophers?
And this kind of question,
it feels like something
a kid would ask their
parents today, just
replace the word
philosopher with any
of a bunch of other words.
Was this particular theme
of otherness purposeful?
And did you write with any
particular marginalized
communities in mind?
TOM MILLER: I think,
what I wanted to do
was write, again,
specific to the world.
So I didn't want to do a
one-to-one sort of comparison
with immigrants or people of
particular ethnic background
or sexual orientation.
But to think a little bit
about incorporating widely
from each of those.
To me, the important thing
as I was writing it--
because I did not want
this to be about a world--
gosh, what would it be like
if straight white males
were the ones who were
discriminated against?
It's a little bit of
boring question to ask.
And the important thing
that happened as I wrote it
was more and more,
that insight into--
so, Robert's facing
a lot of opposition
to becoming an
empirical philosopher.
Danielle, who's his best friend
and eventually, his girlfriend,
is interested in
going the other way.
And she's a war hero who
wants to get into politics.
And the opposition
she experiences--
which is probably much
closer to real-world 1917--
is much more intense.
So, did I have a single
population in mind
as I wrote it?
No, but I hope that
there's enough in common
between sort of what's faced
by any particular marginalized
group--
be it, to some extent, a
midwesterner at Harvard,
somebody who is 10 years
older than his medical school
classmates, or one of the
first men at Radcliffe.
Some of that this is
a little bit the same,
or some of those feelings
are a little bit the same,
regardless.
ERIN SODERBERG: Great.
So you mentioned
Danielle, who's one
of the many female
characters in the book.
And this is another aspect of
this book that I just love.
So because Robert is
at an all girls school
and he was raised by
his mom and his sisters,
he is surrounded by
strong, powerful women
who are all uniquely capable.
They're all
intelligent and strong
but in vastly different ways.
And I'm curious about where
you got the inspiration for so
many diverse female characters.
And are any of them based
on the women in your life?
TOM MILLER: I would say, pretty
much no, autobiographically.
Maybe taking a little bit
composites of people I knew.
Particularly, in
the sequel, which
is a much more military setting
when I wasn't sure what to do,
I just asked, what would
one of the female trauma
surgeons I've worked with
say in this situation?
It was often a useful exercise.
But let's see, Gertrude who was
on today, if she were a man,
I think would be quite a sort
of boring, straightforward
character.
She's the R. Lee
Emery character--
I've got the name
slightly wrong.
She's a drill instructor from
"Full Metal Jacket," she just
happens to be a grandmother, and
limited in what profanity she's
allowed to use.
Likewise, Emaline,
I think, if she
were Robert's dad
would say, well, that's
something like
the Great Santini.
This is a retired
military officer.
He's kind of strict
in a discipline area.
And this is the son who wants to
follow in those same footsteps.
But in the simple
inversion of gender,
I don't know, something
becomes different
or slightly uncomfortable about
it, in a productive way to me.
ERIN SODERBERG: Yeah, there
are many fantasy novels
in the world, but
not many that feature
as many uniquely interesting
female characters as this one
does.
I appreciate that.
TOM MILLER: Well, excellent.
ERIN SODERBERG: So,
about another character
who I find particularly
interesting, Dean Murchison.
Is he based on anyone
you actually knew?
A professor you had, maybe?
TOM MILLER: He is not.
The special assistant
Dean is based
on any number of very
efficient sort of assistance
to department chairs,
or things like
that I've met over the years.
Dean Murchison himself is
one of the rare other male
philosophers.
And he's quite powerful
in his own confused way.
So he's a cartogromancer.
He has sort of mapmaking magic.
And that is driven to a
large extent by a really
exquisite sixth sense,
a sense of position
or distance between
things that he has.
And that is so
overwhelming to him,
that that's sort of the only
thing he's aware of at times.
So somebody is asking him a
question from two feet away,
but he's like, let's see,
there's a stone under my floor.
And that's 2 and 1/2 feet away.
And it's 600 million years old.
And it's a piece of slate.
Like, hey, can you sign?
Can you sign the form, please?
What?
So that's him.
No, not based on any one person.
ERIN SODERBERG: And I
have a follow-up question
about Dean Murchison.
So as you pointed
out, sometimes, he
seems to have difficulty being
pulled into the real world
that he's actually living in.
And some of what he says strikes
true, gets right to the point.
And other times, he seems
to be speaking in riddles.
Should I, as a
reader, spend time
trying to make meaning out
of those parts of his speech?
TOM MILLER: So, he's sort of the
opposite of the usual Cassandra
paradox, which, if I
remember the story right,
was a soothsayer prophet
in Greek mythology.
She could see the
future, but she
was cursed when she got
the gift of foresight,
that no one would
believe what she said.
Everybody knows that
Murchison's predictions
are pretty accurate.
But he's sort of cursed
with talking so obliquely,
that even though they know
what he's saying is important,
or even if Robert is eventually
able to get to that point.
So, yes, what he says
is important or accurate
or with foreknowledge.
But I don't know I would
spend too much time
trying to puzzle it out.
It will become clear in the end.
ERIN SODERBERG: OK,
that's good to know.
So, one of the parts
of your history
is that you studied at Harvard.
And the novel takes
place in Boston.
And I'm wondering
how much of what
you wrote here was influenced
by your own experiences there?
TOM MILLER: So, I
started there at in 1999.
And so, one of the interesting
historical curiosities
is, I believe, up until
1972, Harvard was all men.
So they did not become co-ed
until probably about 27 years
or so before I started there.
There were still
faculty who remembered
that time and sort
of remembered how
badly a lot of the women
at that time were treated.
And sort of in a
counter revealing way,
there were certain
of my classmates
whose fathers and
grandfathers had gone there.
I didn't know anybody who'd
gone there before I went there.
But within a generation or
two, my classmates sort of
had this nostalgia for
a time when it was--
not that they'd ever
been there at the time.
But the sort of familial
nostalgia for it
in a way that it felt
was really strange.
It's not 1979, It's 1999.
How can we possibly still
be having that conversation?
ERIN SODERBERG: So, a follow-up
question about Harvard.
Are the Cocks and
Hens-- which is
a secret society in this novel--
based on a real secret society
at Harvard?
And did you participate in one?
TOM MILLER: I was not a
secret society sort of guy.
I was in an improv
comedy group who--
when I sort of auditioned
and was successful--
they came to my dorm
room sort of dressed
in dark coats and
sunglasses like they
were the mafia or something.
And then, we went
out and had pizza.
And it was a silly thing.
But there is this
split second where
I'm like, what have
I gotten myself--
it's a funny thing.
So a tiny bit based on that.
My wife, who I also met
while I was in college--
was in the Radcliffe
choral society.
Harvard and Radcliffe
had merged by that point.
But some of the old
names still remained.
So they actually came and
very sweetly sang outside
of the window, and
they gave you a flower
and went out for pizza.
So I'm somewhere, I guess,
on average between those.
ERIN SODERBERG: Is
there anything else
from your personal history
that you drew from a lot
when writing?
TOM MILLER: So I would say
my time in EMS in particular.
I was an EMT basic
in the Pittsburgh
area for about four years.
So if you called 911
after about 150 hours
at the Community College
of Allegheny County,
I was the guy who pulled
up in the ambulance.
Particularly, that idea of not
knowing what you're going into,
or having a pretty good idea of
what you're going into and then
being completely wrong.
So that informed sort
of the opening rescue
sequence a little bit.
Later on, as Robert is trying
to get into a burning building
to save somebody, and
one thing goes wrong
and then things start
spiraling out of control,
I would say that is not
based on any one thing
that I did, but sort of
under those high stress
situations as things
begin going wrong,
or as you try to fix
a problem by creating
an even bigger problem.
Some of that has
filtered into it.
ERIN SODERBERG: So
there's a mantra
in the book that gets
repeated several times, which
is try less hard.
Where did that come from?
And do you find it useful in
your own life as a writer,
or as a doctor?
TOM MILLER: That's maybe
something I aspire to,
but I can't claim to put it into
use as much as I would like.
That's in part
based on my college
roommate who was a rower, and
was a better rower than I was.
But our dorm had one of
the eight man crew shells
that we rowed on, like
intramural rowing.
So we rowed against
the other dorms.
So he sat directly behind me.
I was not a great rower.
I was accused of trying to
stroke the boat from the number
six seat.
You all have to move at
exactly the same time.
So if there's one
person who has sort
of independent ideas
about how fast he'd
like to be rowing, that is out
of sync with everybody else,
that's a big problem.
So he would be sitting
behind me going,
relax, relax, in sort
of the same fashion.
So I sort of thought of
him as I wrote that line.
But sort of that idea of
making things look easy
or some of the greatest
competence being
able to do sort of high pressure
things in a relaxed way,
certainly, is
applicable to what I
do in medicine, though
I am a long way off most
days, from getting there.
ERIN SODERBERG: So many
of my fellow Googlers
also pursue various artistic
pursuits in their free time.
What advice do you
have for people
whose full time
profession like yours
is something other than
writing, but who wish
to write a novel themselves?
TOM MILLER: So if taking two
years off from your main career
is not an option, what I'd
done for a long time was
sort of block out space
every day to write.
And that was the
one piece of advice
I'd probably gotten a dozen or
100 times in my life, which,
if you want to get
good at writing,
you have to do it every day.
If you want to finish a project,
And it took me a really long
time to take that to heart.
Went to grad school
for creative writing.
I certainly was writing every
day when I had the time,
or when that was
my full time job.
But as things got
rolling in the book,
I hit a point where it was
sort of like a self-sustaining
reaction almost, where it
got easier instead of harder,
and were the habit of
writing every day--
even if it was just for 15
or 20 minutes before bed--
became easier to
do than not to do.
And the other
advice I've heard is
if you can write one page a
day, by the end of the year,
you'll have a novel's
worth of pages.
Whether it's any good
or not, whether you then
spend seven years revising
it, is a different question.
But write every day if you're
trying to write a novel.
ERIN SODERBERG:
So, another thing
that definitely
strikes me as I read
this particular novel
is that it would
translate very well as a movie.
Many of the scenes
are very visual
and you can picture
exactly what's happening.
So is that going to happen?
I hope it happens.
TOM MILLER: There's been a
little bit of talk about it,
but nothing concrete.
ERIN SODERBERG: And if
that were to happen,
do you have any
particular actors in mind
for any of the main roles?
TOM MILLER: So, none of
the characters in the book
are supposed to be very good--
maybe with the exception of Jake
and Mayweather-- none of them
are supposed to be
very good looking.
So I imagine Robert as
sort of a young less good
looking Vin Diesel with hair.
ERIN SODERBERG: Oh, sure.
Yeah, I can picture that.
What about Danielle?
TOM MILLER: I have not yet
seen the right person for her.
I don't know.
Who do you see as Danielle?
ERIN SODERBERG: That's
a good question.
I'm also not sure.
I'll have to think about
that and get back to you.
So that was the
last question I had.
I'm going to open
it up now and see
if anyone else has any
questions they'd like to ask.
And if you ask, I can repeat
it so that you can hear.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
I think my first
question is, so when
I read the synopsis
of your book,
I decided to come to this.
Two of my favorite
trilogies-- like,
fantasy trilogies of all
time-- are "His Dark Materials"
by Philip Pullman, and
the Abhorsen trilogy,
which is like
"Sabriel," "Lirael".
And the reason I bring that up
is because both of those books
are kind of set in these--
it's kind of this
historical setting,
but things went in a
different direction.
In the case of "Sabriel" and
"Lirael," it's like it's magic,
but they don't call it magic.
And they do different things.
And I guess I was wondering if
you had other books that you
kind of drew inspiration from
for such a creative scene.
TOM MILLER: Yeah, I encountered
both of those series relatively
late in my life.
So Philip Pullman
probably was when
I was a junior or
senior in college
that I read those
for the first time.
I've read "Sabriel",
which has bell ringing
magic, essentially, which
is not like anything I've
seen elsewhere.
It was really striking to me.
And it was an instance to
me of a male writer writing
a teenage sort of late
teens, young woman
character in a pretty good way.
I thought Garth Nix, to my
eye, or to my ear, at least,
did a nice job with it.
The two books or two
series, I would say,
most directly
influenced this one.
One would be "Jonathan
Strange and Mr. Norrell"
which was a historical fantasy
novel set in the Napoleonic
Wars.
It was written in about 2004,
I think, by Susannah Clark.
Much more high-minded,
much more sort
of literary in what it
tried to do, particularly
in terms of the
prose style, where
I was trying to write something
a little bit planar, both
because I thought
it would be more
accessible, and ultimately,
because that was
the voice of that character
was a sort of plainspoken sort
of simple-spoken westerner.
The other series that
came to mind to me a lot
as I was trying to figure
out how to write the book
and structure the
book was one that I
had read sort of probably
in my mid-teens, which
was the "Farseer"
trilogy by Robin Hobb.
Structurally, it used--
and I've seen it elsewhere.
It's in "Ender's Game."
It's in "Starship Troopers,"
but the idea of somebody
looking back from
middle age reflecting
on more youthful adventures,
so little bit of that narrative
distance which was
useful, and then starting
each of the chapters with
an epigram or a piece
of that world to help
with world building
in a way that doesn't
necessarily muck up the plot
or slow things down.
And people can read it or
puzzle over those things,
or not, as they choose.
AUDIENCE: And then, my second
question is sort of a follow-up
to your first question about
I've played around the idea
of writing a book for
a very long time--
very, very, very long time.
And I've written short stories.
But I'm not consistent.
I guess, one question
I have for you
is, did you have a
moment where you're
doing all this other stuff.
You've clearly been to
grad school a few times.
So have I. Did you ever
just wake up one day
and just decide,
I need to focus.
I have a good idea.
I need to focus on this.
I really need to kind of start?
TOM MILLER: It was my New Year's
resolution for 2010, was I
was going to write every day.
I think I kept it with--
I maybe missed two days
or so over the following
six or seven years.
So, yes, there was a day.
And then, once I decided
I was going to do it,
but it was like--
I don't know-- October,
November of '09.
I'm like, well, I might
as well start now.
Part of that was
the time pressure
because I started
medical school in 2010.
I'm working I'm working a couple
of different jobs part time
right now.
I have time, particularly, as
I sort of taper down and get
set to start school again.
So this is the time to do it.
And if I don't
get a lot of pages
down, if I don't get a
rough draft together now,
it's probably never
going to happen.
So I may as well try.
AUDIENCE: And was it always
kind of this book in particular
you were writing?
Or were you kind of playing
around with other ideas?
TOM MILLER: I played around
with many things over the years.
But this is one of the
things I keep coming back to.
And the first sketches
they did toward it
were probably as early as 2004.
I was a travel
writer at that time.
I was down in New
Zealand doing a couple
of the great walks, which
were these multi-day hikes.
I was doing it quite
late in the year,
so there were not a lot of
other people out on the trails.
And I kept getting lost.
So that's sort of where the
mapmaking magic came from.
But I found it a
really appealing world
and an appealing idea.
I kept coming back to it,
would write a few pages,
and then set it aside
for months or years.
One danger of that
approach, I think,
is that you can
know too well what
you want to do or be too
unwilling to discard things.
So ultimately, in the revising,
which took the longest time,
it was trying to
streamline things
and trying to drop a
little bit of the things
that I've been doing,
just because, well, that's
how I'd been doing it.
But does it make sense?
Or is it useful to the story?
And that's something I had
to figure out in revising,
rather than primary writing.
ERIN SODERBERG:
All right, I think
that brings us to a conclusion.
Thank you so much, Tom, for
visiting us and telling us
all about "The
Philosopher's Flight."
TOM MILLER: Well, Erin,
thanks for having me today.
And thanks to our tech crew too,
who were laboring quite a bit.
When nice and smooth.
ERIN SODERBERG: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]